hey this is presh tollwacker there's a
question making the rounds The Daily
Mail reports GCSE pupils fume over
sadistic last question in Edexcel Matt's
paper
so what is this fiendishly difficult
question
here's the diagram
eight identical regular octagons each
with side length x enclose a shape
what is the area of the enclosed shape
write your answer in the form P
multiplied by the term two plus root 2
multiplied by x squared where p is an
integer
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
there are many ways to approach the
problem but here's how I approached it
I thought about the enclosed shape and I
broke it down into shapes that I would
be able to calculate the area of
one shape is a quadrilateral with four
equal sides we are going to show that
this is a square
then we have four triangles here and
we're going to show that there are four
right triangles
so let's get started by analyzing the
angle between two octagons
let's zoom in on the enclosed shape
from one octagon extend the side so that
Theta is an exterior angle of the
octagon
the formula for an exterior angle of a
regular polygon is that the exterior
angle is equal to 360 Degrees divided by
n where n is the number of sides
in this case we have an octagon which
has eight sides so Theta is equal to 360
Degrees divided by 8 which is equal to
45 degrees
now we also have an X here angle here
so the angle between two octagons is
equal to two Theta and that's equal to
90 degrees
so every pair of octagons meet at a 90
degree angle
so we can now go back to the original
diagram
we know that every single angle between
two octagons is 90 degrees so all of
these are right angles
therefore the quadrilateral with four
equal sides must be a square
and these triangles are all right
triangles and they're isosceles right
triangles
so each leg of this right triangle is a
side of the Octagon so it has length
equal to X
the hypotenuse of this right triangle is
equal to the square root of x squared
plus x squared which is equal to X root
2.
now to calculate the side length of the
square we have two more sides of the
octagon
so this is equal to X and this is equal
to X so the total side length of the
square is equal to 2x plus X root 2.
and each right triangle has side length
equal to X
so we'll just focus on the areas of
these two shapes
so the area of the square is equal to
the square of its side length so that's
the square of 2x plus X root 2.
this equals 4x squared plus 4x squared
root 2 plus 2x squared
this simplifies to be 6X squared plus
four x squared root 2.
the area of each right triangle is equal
to x times x all over 2 which is x
squared over 2
we want four of these triangles so this
simplifies to be 2x squared
we now want to add these areas
we have 6X squared plus 4x squared root
2 plus 2x squared this equals eight x
squared plus 4x squared root 2. we can
factor out 4x squared and we multiply
this by the term 2 plus root 2.
now we want to write this answer with x
squared on the right side of the
parentheses so this is equal to 4
multiplied by the term 2 plus root 2
multiplied by x squared and that is the
answer in the form that they've
requested it what an interesting
question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
thank you